chief petty officer Rob Roy spent more
than two decades serving in the US Navy
is a special operator yes on seal team
six he's a quiet professional but he is
here to talk about the Navy SEAL art of
war his new book Rob there are you know
SEAL Teams like to talk about there
being officers and door kickers you were
a door kicker yes and in your book you
talk about how important it is both for
corporations and the military to move
responsibilities down the idea of the
strategic corporal what does that mean
for corporations or what it means
everybody has to be has not have buy-in
but everybody has to be immersed in what
the company is trying to do a [ __ ]
what they're trying to achieve so if I
know what the what my commander wants
the outcome to be from any particular
mission or any for corporations products
that have a better understanding what my
role is in that and making sure that
product comes to market and if they
don't understand that it it creates a
lag or in our profession it creates kind
of a hiccup but in the combat which cost
you your life and that's that's changed
within both the navy and the marine
corps that has that actually happened
that where it's been where authorities
been moved down to the Corporal would
its pass down the commander's intent
everybody works with the commander's
intent and understand what that mission
is supposed to be and then based on your
training and and your leaders everybody
understands the goal of that mission and
they try to accomplish so you sit down
at Dumbarton and the kids again a bunch
of bright-eyed MBAs who've never worked
with the seals or anything military
command and control kind of performance
what will be your number one advice to
Dumbarton mission focus and how do you
prepare do you project what you're what
you want to have happen to the people
that work for you and how is that
information passed down and then more
importantly how are you verify that
information tech some impact as part of
that you got to get out there and see
people I still don't see any substitute
for travel management has to get out
there and talk to people face-to-face
and we gonna be on that won't know you
wonder percent you have to have some
kind of connection with the people that
are working for you in order for them to
implement your ideas because if you're
the lady river if you're a leader of a
group or organization you really have to
impress upon them who you are what you
want the money we deal with this
predator Bloomberg every single day is
no substitute for getting out this is an
amazing organization that works
perfectly and need your help to nob
one of the things that you do now is you
work with corporations and of course
your book is also designed for a
corporate audience and this is part of
America's love affair right now with the
Navy SEAL one of the things that we see
within the Pentagon is that the special
operations budget either stays the same
or increases even as other things are
getting cut back is a very important
part of strategy for the u.s. do you
worry at all that as we all become as we
all come to think of the Navy SEAL as
America's superhero that they are then
quietly special operators asked to carry
too much of the burden strategically
because we believe that they can do
anything I believe that one hundred
percent to be true I think that the more
success that they have the more people
want to give them but there's only so
many hours in a day to train people
there's only so many deployments they
can actually do before you reach with a
call and there are problem training
enough guys to do this correct right
there's an old system that needs to be
put in place room when the kids are
coming out of high school so they go to
college and then going on to the Special
Operations community but then within the
community there's a problem right now I
understand with retention because
they're being asked to carry so much of
the burden of national security well I
would put it more in line of the
deployment schedules for the guys are a
little bit more extreme than they were a
couple years ago so if the deployment
schedules are keeping them on the road
for more than you know six months or
eight months at a time then they have no
time to recover you have to allow your
people to recover yeah and that's the
more important important thing is that
if your if your organization is really
driving the driving the drive driving
them to to be successful in if you don't
give them time to recover relax and
recoup and retrain and you have an
underscore this is to the heart of your
previous argument which is that boots on
the ground is tough when you're
exhausted well that yeah i mean my
question for you is what do you think
about the use of special operations
forces in afghan
and I rat was it successful in achieving
the bigger Scott strategic goals I think
so because the enemy NASA know who we
are what we are capable of doing you
can't win a war if the interview doesn't
know who you are you get you have to
strike fear in the hearts of the people
that you're that you're engaging it's so
different than the business of your
competitors they have to know that
you're gonna be one hundred percent on
them all the time that we've got a
number of special forces in the military
is some 60,000 there something and then
how many Navy SEALs are there is that
classified or do we know it's roughly
around 1800 to 2000 depending on you
know the time of that time of year but
it's but yeah it's about 2,000 people
total but probably 1800 guys are
deployed or you know how many people
wash up you know I say that with great
respect to the college's of becoming
anniversary self-selection you know you
get a kid that wants to be in the Navy
yeah we could want to become a Navy SEAL
who doesn't have all the tools he goes
to the program and it's too much for him
you're gonna have a eighty percent drop
out rate foot because of lack of
knowledge even though there's a lot of
stuff on the internet and there's a lot
of stuff that tell the movies but kids
see their kids there are 18 year old
kids to try to make a decision do you
like the way you are personified in the
movies today I mean every other movies a
total blow up military movie well you
sit in the theater what do you think of
those I think it's hard to capture what
seals actually do because there's a
humility with all the guy there's also a
humor that they have creativity the
fiscal pressures they're under on a
day-to-day basis i think the quiet
professionalism is the right approach
for our community but it's really hard
it's not excited enough for people to
watch on television Bradley Cooper's not
as good-looking as you is probably thank
you so much to Navy SEAL Navy SEAL art
of war smart sharp book for corporate
America Rob Roy thank you so much